Hi everyone.
I want to tell you about an event that's
going to take place in Toronto on July
18th at 7:30 PM it's going to be held at
the Canada Christian College 50 Jervais
drive in Toronto.
The event is entitled Bill See 16 one
year later,
sex ideology and compelled speech in
Canada and here.
Here's the background detail.
Bill [inaudible] has incorporated gender
identity and expression and to Canadian
human rights law and the criminal code
within a broader policy context
predicated on the idea that gender is
solely a social construct.
The effect is rippling through the
social world affecting schools,
universities,
the healthcare systems,
the law and journalism.
What implications does this have for
free speech?
What punitive measures can and does the
law imposed on those who violate its
provisions?
There is no scientific evidence that
supports the idea that gender and sex
and biology and sexual proclivity very
independently,
but that position is now instantiated
into Canadian law.
The following four panelists will
discuss these issues and more.
Lindsay Shepherd.
Lindsay rose to prominence after staff
at Wilfrid laurier university,
subjected her to a disciplinary hearing
for showing a video discussing bill see
16 to her students while she was serving
as a teaching assistant that produced
the biggest scandal in Canadian
university history and very little
evidence by the way that Wilfrid laurier
university learned its lesson.
She will be speaking at this event about
the tactics and effects of trans
activism on university campuses.
Barbara K we'll also speak she's a
teacher,
author and an influential columnist for
the Canadian newspaper,
the National Post.
She will be speaking on the impact
suppression of free speech is having on
journalism illustrating with the
personal experiences she and others have
had in the areas of indigenous
correctness.
She was fired as a regular contributor
to a CBC radio show for incorrect
remarks made elsewhere.
She will speak about the phenomenon
known in Arabic as Ketman defined by one
scholar as the position taken by those
who desire to be at one with others in
order not to be alone.
Dr Deborah,
so we'll speak as well.
She holds a Phd From York University and
writes about the science and politics of
sex and culture.
Dr So is a columnist for playboy.com and
the globe and mail.
Her writing has been widely featured in
such publications as Harper's The Wall
Street Journal and the La Times.
She will be discussing the science of
gender,
what makes someone feel female or male
and why gender ideology which denies the
influence of biology is harmful as she
states.
The common belief nowadays is that
gender is a spectrum and that sexual
orientation,
gender identity and gender are
unrelated.
This is not what the scientific research
indicates.
Jared Brown rounds out the panel.
He's lead counsel at Brown litigation
aiding his clients in matters relating
to commercial and employment disputes,
breaches of contract,
shareholder disputes and collection of
accounts.
Last year he spoke to the Canadian
Senate about the dangers of bill.
See 16 jared will be speaking about the
legal aspects of [inaudible] including
its legislation of compelled speech,
the opinions of Canadian and US courts
regarding such speech and his experience
of the subterfuge and dishonesty of the
proponents of the legislation.
In his words,
the politicking behind the scenes of my
appearance at the Senate made it clear
that the intention of the proponents was
to control speech all along.
Serena sing will moderate.
Serena is an ex social worker and an
emerging political and social
commentator.
She organized the largest discussion on
free speech ever held in Canada on
November 11th,
2017 as well as this one year later
event.
I'm really interested in this gathering.
I'm going to try to make it at least to
attend and listen.
Although I'm coming back from London
that day,
and if there's any delays,
I won't be able to manage it.
But I would strongly encourage everyone
who can manage it to go and listen to
these panelists.
It's an important discussion and uh,
it should be an extraordinarily
interesting event.
Thanks for your attention.
Bye Bye.